forschende haben eine bestürzende
entdeckung gemacht der zwergplanet pluto
verliert in dramatischer geschwindigkeit
seiner atmosphäre bei diesem video ist
übrigens team von astor comics tv dabei
eine meiner lieblings kanäle unbedingt
abonnieren der link ist hier unter also
alles zum pluto erfahrt ihr hier jetzt
bei pixum science reviews los geht's
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen clixoom geht es
jetzt übrigens auch als podcast auf die
ohren die links spotify und apple
podcasts sind in der video beschreibung
den kleinen trifft es wirklich hart
nachdem man ihn schon 2006 seinen status
als planet beraubt hatte verliert er
jetzt auch noch seine atmosphäre
der zwergplanet pluto kommt einfach
nicht zur ruhe und das fing schon früh
an vor fast 100 jahren einige von euch
kennen sicherlich noch den merck spruch
mit dem man sich die planeten behalten
kann der geht wie folgt mein vater
erklärt mir jeden sonntag unsere neun
planeten die anfangsbuchstaben stehen
dafür für die jeweiligen planeten namen
also mein gleich merkur vater gleich
venus und so weiter leider hat dieser
spruch seit na ja jetzt schon 14 jahren
nicht mehr so ganz hin denn seitdem
haben wir nur noch acht planeten pluto
rausgeflogen ist wie konnte es dazu
kommen
eigentlich war alles gut im jahre 1930
hat er erst 24 jährige amerikaner clyde
tombaugh pluto entdeckt und damals war
man sich sofort einig dass es sich
hierbei um einen planeten handeln muss
damals schon lange vermutet hat das sich
irgendwo hinter neptun noch ein neunter
planet befindet alle waren so begeistert
dass sogar walt disney den hund von
micky maus nach den neuen zwergplaneten
pluto benannt hat doch im laufe der
jahre wurden auch die teleskope immer
besser und man stellte dann nach und
nach test dass pluto viel kleiner ist
als man ursprünglich dachte und der
todesstoß der kam dann im jahre 2003 da
hat man nämlich den heutigen
zwergplaneten eris entdeckt hinter pluto
und er ist ungefähr gleich gross wie
pluto das heißt im prinzip hatten die
wissenschaftler jetzt nur noch zwei
alternativen entweder er es auch zum
planeten machen zum zehnten planeten
oder er ist nicht dazu nehmen weil er so
klein ist aber dann musste man ja auch
pluto raus wäre
und dann ist ja genauso klein und das
kann dann echt zu einer super spannenden
konferenz der internationalen
astronomischen union das sind also die
top astronomen der welt und die
beschließen an allerlei sachen und die
haben sich 2006 in prag getroffen und
mit einer ganz knappen mehrheits
entscheidung dafür gestimmt dass pluto
rausfliegt als pluto da kein planet mehr
war stellte sich die frage was ist er
dann und man hat dann für ehre und pluto
den neuen begriff zwergplanet erfunden
und damals haben sie sehr viele leute
aufgeregt es gab dann protestmärsche und
fanclubs und so und alle haben gefordert
dass pluto wieder zum planeten gemacht
wird ich habe auch sympathien für pluto
aber ich glaube das ist die richtige
entscheidung warten zu degradieren
das problem ist dass es mittlerweile
noch weitere zwergplaneten geht neben
eris und pluto hat man nämlich noch
macke marke tewes und mehr entdeckt und
wer pluto wieder zum planeten machen
will der müsste die alle zu planeten
machen forscher glauben sogar dass es im
hinteren sonnensystem hunderte
zwergplaneten geben könnte
und wenn wir die alle zu planeten machen
dann wird es ein bisschen inflationär
oder was man die schreibt uns mal an die
kommentare war es wichtig kultur
rauszuschmeißen oder sollte er wieder
ein planet werden ganz schön bewegende
geschichte für so einen kleinen
himmelskörper und jetzt auch noch das
pluto verliert seine atmosphäre
viele sind verwundert dass pluto
überhaupt eine atmosphäre besitzt denn
normalerweise ist dies eher den größeren
himmelskörpern vergönnt eine atmosphäre
ist eine art schutzhülle um einen
planeten und kann sogar in diesem fall
um ein zwerg planeten und kann sogar
eben leben ermöglichen unsere
erdatmosphäre schützt uns beispielsweise
vor gefährlicher weltraum strahlung und
bewahrt uns davor nachts zu erfrieren
deshalb ist es auch so wichtig dass wir
unsere atmosphäre beschützen und
gefährliche treibhausgase eindämmen doch
auch kleinere himmelskörper können eine
dünne atmosphäre besitze bluetooth
gravitation genügt um eine solche
schutzhülle ausbilden zu können und
astronomen und astronomen haben vor
einigen jahren sogar herausgefunden dass
seine atmosphäre dichter zu werden
scheint man erklärte sich das mit
bluetooth elliptische umlaufbahn um die
sonne
die distanz des zwergplaneten zu unserem
heimatstern schwankt nämlich erheblich
an seinem sonnen fernsten punkt ist er
milliarden kilometer entfernt an seinem
sonnennächsten punkt nur nur 4,4
milliarden kilometer wenn er der sonne
näher ist führt die höhere temperatur
dazu dass die ice vorkommen auf pluto
beginnen zu verdampfen diese bestehen
aus stickstoff methan und kohlenstoff
die dann gasförmig in die oberen
atmosphärenschichten aufsteigen und
insgesamt dazu führen dass plutos
atmosphäre sich verdichtet sobald blut
und sich dann wieder von der sonne
entfernt sinken die temperaturen große
teile seiner atmosphäre gefrieren und es
kommt zu heftigen 1 stürmen bei denen
gigantische hagen körner aus stickstoff
und methan auf der oberfläche
ausschlagen vermutlich eines der
spektakulärsten ereignisse im
sonnensystem
dieser zyklus müsste eigentlich zu einer
gleichmäßigen entwicklung vom pluto
atmosphäre für mal ist dichter mal
dünner da pluto sich seit einigen jahren
von der sonne entfernt haben
berechnungen gezeigt dass sein
atmosphärendruck seit 2016 um circa ein
prozent gefallen sein müsste doch jetzt
die spektakuläre beobachtungen entgegen
dieser vorhersagen ist sein
atmosphärendruck um über 20% gefallen
also im prinzip kollabiert festgestellt
hat man dies durch eine raffinierte
methode man verwendet das licht weit
entfernter sterne wenn diese genau
hinter pluto stehen und ihr licht durch
seine atmosphäre scheint wenn man dieses
sternenlicht dann mit speziellen
teleskopen auf der erde untersucht kann
man genau feststellen wie bluetooth
atmosphäre das sternenlicht verändert
hat und dadurch dann angaben über die
atmosphäre selber machen warum die
atmosphäre vom pluto jetzt so kollabiert
das ist ein großes rätsel
denn alleine die unterschiedlich
entfernung zur sonne die kann das nicht
erklären es müsste also auf blut und
auch weitere dynamische prozesse geben
wie zb geothermie von einigen mond von
saturn und jupiter wie zb europa oder
enceladus ist bekannt dass es dort eis
vulkanismus gibt die schwerkraft der
gasriesen die knete die monde durch und
das geschmolzene sprit als flüssiges
wasser an der oberfläche raus das nennt
man im eis vulkanismus oder chris muss
auf pluto könnte es methan oder
stickstoff vulkane geben die die
zusammen
der atmosphäre beeinflussen doch dann
wäre zu klären welche kräfte den
vulkanismus auf pluto antreiben
denn eine gravitation wie sie von
jupiter oder saturn ausgeht die wird ja
oft blutig deswegen ist das auch nur
eine theorie jetzt werden sogar einige
die these auf dass es auf pluto
außerirdisches leben geben könnte also
vielleicht alien bakterien die in den
dicken eisschichten leben in den metall
und stickstoff eis und durch ihren
stoffwechsel die zusammensetzung der
atmosphäre beeinflussen
der astrophysiker william mckinnon der
formuliert es so für irdische bakterien
oder sogar andere lebewesen wie fische
wie wir sie von der erde kennen gibt es
auch pluto keine grundlage doch ähnlich
wie in den methan sehen ob saturns
größte mond titan werten diese
forschungsergebnisse den verdacht auf ob
nicht gänzlich neue lebensformen in
diesen kalten und einzigartigen
flüssigkeiten leben können für die
weitere erforschung von pluto kommt ein
problem hinzu denn aus unserer sicht
bewegt er sich aus richtung des
galaktischen zentrums weg das heißt er
bewegt sich jetzt in eine position in
der hinter ihm regionen der milchstraße
zu sehen sind in denen viel weniger
sterne sind die wahrscheinlichkeit dass
stern sich dann durch bluetooth
atmosphäre fällt dies also viel geringer
es wäre schon großes glück wenn es uns
in den kommenden jahr noch mal gelingen
würde sternen nicht aufzufangen das
durch plutos atmosphäre durch geschehen
ist unsere beste hoffnung um mehr über
den mysteriösen zwergplanet
herauszufinden ist es in größere und
bessere teleskope zu investieren
eigentlich sollte in den nächsten jahren
ja das james webb teleskop an den start
gehen ein weltraumteleskop das deutlich
besser sein wird als das hubble teleskop
und das hat ja schon spektakuläre bilder
und erkenntnisse geliefert das james
webb teleskop soll vor allem
spektakuläre fotos im infrarotbereich
machen können und könnte und so
detaillierte aufnahmen von der
zusammensetzung von bluetooth atmosphäre
liefern doch leider wurde der start ist
james webb teleskop in den letzten
jahren immer weiter nach hinten
verschoben und die arbeit daran wurde
wegen der korona pandemie nun erneut
unterbrochen
es sieht also so aus als würde pluto für
uns vorher ist ein großes rätsel bleiben
mehr informationen über den kleinen zwei
planeten erhaltet ihr im teams animation
skript fünf fakten über pluto falls ihr
auf
juni in zeichentrick form stehen
abonnieren unbedingt teams channel astro
comics tv hier findet dort hunderte
galaktisch weltraum clips und können
team helfen sein ziel von 30.000
abonnenten zu erreichen also abonnieren
abonnieren abonnieren und ansonsten bis
dann bleibt dran